how'd you get involved with the Mission
Impossible movies because that's an
amazing franchise was that something was
that something you sought out yeah that
was a really strange experience for me
because I was supposed to I was going in
to meet with JJ Abrams for a movie
called super 8 yes and I had to go in
and talk to him I was it wasn't quite
fueling the part so I sat down and
talked to him he's like okay I want to
hear everything that you think about it
but we think about Mission Impossible
and what do you mean he said you won't
you want to meet Tom and Brad Bird those
guys right now I'm like well I thought
we're gonna talk about super 8 and I was
gonna tell you I can't do the movie it
wasn't it wasn't my thing
right things you know what you want to
go meet Tom that guy is like Tom Cruise
ya know says that yeah so I'm like okay
he's like opens the door and he's in
there guys right I keep him here for but
yeah so we left the meeting in Santa
Monica I could go over to Paramount that
over there so I'm like alright I'll just
go say hi to the guys and talk about it
should impossible now and so I sit in a
room with Tom and Brad Bird and another
producer talked about the script that
doesn't exist in a movie I didn't
knowing about and like you want to do it
I'm like oh I don't know it sounds
cooler like you guys like your movie but
we want me to do I meet so I was kind of
like a weird like bro hug until all the
three guys at the end of it and like
okay I'll talk to you later and I Drive
home and my phone rings in my house and
Tom calling first of all like how'd you
get my number can pick up any phone and
get get me jeremy renner yeah any con
okay by hopeful I don't even know my
home phone number somehow you know and
he's like - are we doing this we doing
this I'm like I well yeah I guess we are
so then no I was doing that story would
infuriate any actor right who's had
who's like struck out you go to a
meeting with JJ Abrams is like yeah I
really want you in this film but let's
go meet Tom Cruise cuz we want to put
you in another film that isn't even
written yet and then Tom's calling you
at home yeah and I can see you right now
it was it was a very strange experience
it doesn't really happen and yeah in
this town fantastic that would be pretty
amazing experience unless hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos